الذكاء الاصطناعي بات يباغت عالمنا خلسه
ويؤثر في جميع المجالات بما في ذلك
الصحافه موقع اكسيوس في احدث منشوراته سلط
الضوء على مدى الحاجه الملحه لوكالات
الاخباري وشركات البث لتتبنى العمل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي والا فانها ستتخلف عن
الركب
لكن لا يتفق جميع ناشر الاخبار مع هذا
الراي حيث شددت محرره صحيفه في رساله
حديثه على ضروره امتناع دور النشر عن
استخدام ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي مهما كلف
الامر وان جميع تقاريرها سوف تتم كتابتها
وتحريرها من قبل اشخاص من النخبه في
مجالاتهم حسب قولها
معارضه بعض الناشرين للذكاء الاصطناعي
تنبع من تهديده لارادتهم فجلهم يعتمدون
على نظام الاشتراك المدفوع ومن غير المرجح
اي يؤيدوا فكره مشاطره بياناتهم مع
روبوتات الدردشه دون مقابل ناشرون كثر
ايضا يساورهم القلق من قدره الذكاء
الاصطناعي على تقليص نسبه زياده مواقعهم
الالكترونيه فضلا عن زياده مخاطر فضائح
حقوق النشر لهذا السبب قامت بعض ودور
النشر مثل نيويورك تايمز واشنطن بوست وفيس
ميديا
بالتواصل بالفعل مع شركات التكنولوجيا
لبرام اتفاق يتم بموجبه اتاحه المحتوى
الخاص بهم لبرامج الدردشه مقابل رسوم
خلافا لصحيفه فنان شال تايمز التي ترفض
الذكاء الاصطناعي جمله وتفصيلا على الاقل
حاليا رحبت بازفيد به بشده لتقديم
المساعده في برامج الترفيه والمسابقات
ووفقا لمقال نشرته صرحت الشركه 12% من
القوى العامله لديها في ديسمبر 2022
ترى بعض الوسائل الاعلاميه ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سيكون جزءا لا يتجزا من
المستقبل لدرجه وصلت الى نسب المشاركه في
كتابه بعض الموضوعات
حسبما ذكرت الجاردن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات